[Musique]
gago on connaît le musicien mais il ya
maintenant en france gall ou d'animateur
garou le restaurateur
vous êtes tous à la fois comment vous la
voyez votre aventure française en france
vraiment pour ruse comme si c'était
clair que j'étais pas un français mais
en même temps il oublié complètement que
les ports français donc souvent mais on
me demande d'être à la barre d'un
nouveau de gros évènement vous a dit
qu'il me semble ça apprend que c'est moi
qui a même tel show face tel événement
parce que pourquoi tu es la personne
parfaite et idéal on voit personne d'eau
oui mais je suis pas français a baissé
les gens là ont comblé mon billet c'est
fou
[Musique]
pour pas
bon j'avais commencé à parler comme ça
et devenir français et vous donc vouloir
toi non je suis toujours resté québécois
mon vocabulaire d'abord évidemment parce
que je ne pas comprendre je pense que ce
soit un gag puis mais ouais j'ai c'est
très surprenant c'est que c'est pas
aussi c'est pas juste c'est pas juste
l'artiste c'est vraiment la personne
même quand je me promène parce que j'ai
eu d'autres d'autres affaires
l'album je reste avant un pari qui
marchent merveilleusement bien où on
reçoit plein plein plein mon mais je
suis vraiment considéré comme chez eux
mêmes quand tu es de faire de la musique
et youtube va vous trahir mais vous avez
donné récemment un concert à istanbul en
turquie
non j'en ai fait son avance à istanbul
turquie gago ou sans me fais beaucoup de
pays puis encore on en a rajouté 3
au moins tout le monde novembre j'étais
parti en tournée dans plusieurs pays et
chaque année je vais dans beaucoup de
payer non francophones il ya plusieurs
choses qui ont fait que les méchants
sont se sont promenés dont notre-dame de
paris a beaucoup voyagé
puis dès le début je me suis mis à
voyager avec avec ce j'étais le premier
à la russie par des groupes mon premier
choix du système ainsi une personne donc
la partie comme ça je comprends même pas
pourquoi on m'invitait la pologne en
russie en ukraine puis après ça ça fait
son chemin saint rémy sled un peu
partout puis dès le premier album il ya
une chanson get et chanson de l'année en
pologne et gitans qui avait même pas
faire un numéro un en france avait même
pas été un extrait enfin ce qu'ils
avaient un gros succès dans les pays de
l'est
ramzy
changer tant pis me chante sans
phonétique c'est hallucinant et je les
vois feuillet de chante en français puis
le nombre de témoignages ne peut pas
même pas t'expliquer le nombre de
témoignages que j'ai des gens qui disent
j'ai appris le français
grâce à tes chansons pour cette eau qui
m'a donné le goût d'apprendre le
français
qu'est ce que je peux demander de plus
beau comme cadeau en plus dans notre
dévotion québécoise de cette battue dans
notre histoire toujours pour garder une
france
[Musique]
notre dame de paris ça fait 20 ans quels
souvenirs gardez-vous de cette période
l'offre
[Musique]
ça m'a créé par ailleurs moi qui aimais
beaucoup aller vers les gens allaient
finalement les gens mais peut-on vivre
moi donc ça a été un choc mais que j'ai
bien dû gérer parce que je t'ai bien
accompagné de pas monsieur des tâches
parce que je me suis détaché tellement
de de ce succès le aujourd'hui caisse
mais l'impression que ce qu'aiment les
noms du vilain programme de paris
laissent penser comme c'est lé vin étant
je me suis posé la question ce que je
vais avoir le chauffeur tomberont le
show il ya quelque chose en moi qui
étais comme pas capable de retourner
réveiller ça des fois ci vient pour ce
qu'on vous a pas entendu beaucoup lors
de la finale
non je sais pas si c'est pas du tout
parce que je leur dis au contraire notre
dame de paris la chance de ma vie et
c'est vraiment par un drôle de malaise
comme si c'est revoir une ex que tu as
beaucoup aimé qu'ils étaient mieux ne
pas la voir
vim
là
[Musique]
vous avez une méga carrière en français
vous avez toujours rêvé d'une grande
carrière en anglais non non non en fait
j'ai fait un album en anglais parce que
j'aime beaucoup c'est entendu mais le
rêve d'une carrière américaine le ton je
n'ai jamais puis je me suis jamais
sentie d'aller le évidemment qui
l'équipe de rené et céline eux il y
avait plus cette ambition là mais c'est
plutôt moins qu'ils tiraient sur les
rênes en faisant comme ninon sais pas je
pense la preuve en est que même dans ma
carrière francophones même si je peux
plusieurs pays poussent à je pousse pas
ma carrière je sais lire aime beaucoup
plus que je donne le coup de fouet au
cheval terence plus vite
c'est pas parce que c'est un fainéant
parce qu au contraire jugent plutôt un
goût un vrai vocalique mais j'ai pas
d'énormes ambitions
garou merci mille fois un plaisir